Est qu'il y a quelqu'un qui veut encore se désister c'est maintenant ou jamais, hein.
(Musique stressante film horreur)
Apparemment l’hôtel aurait fermé en 2008.
C'est ouf comme en 9 ans le truc s'est complètement délabré
Oh c'est une sorte de salle karaoké ça !
Putain, dans l'hôtel il y avait des salles..
Pour euh.. Chanter.
Des salles karaoké mon gars.
Ici y a une petite pancarte avec des notes de musique
Et juste là, une sorte de sono.
Et puis même c'est vachement ambiance euh, salle pour euh.. Chanter quoi.
C'est sûr que c'était un karaoké mon gars.
Sûr et certain.
Donc tout à l'heure on était de l'autre côté de ce mur dans les cuisines,
Et là on est... Dans le réfectoire là où les gens mangeaient.
Pouaah
Han y a encore la sauce soja de l'époque !
Mouais elle est pas en bon état... - Elle est pas en bon état effectivement
En fait en bas de l’hôtel il y a un fleuve
Et du coup je pense qu'il y a
y'a beaucoup d'humidité dans l'hotel c'est pour ça qu'il
s'est délabré à ce point. Et c'est triste parce que l'hôtel
Il avait une super vue, en faite en face...
de cette hotel abandonné, y'a un hotel non abandonné
Qui est immense, et donc je pense que celui-là a résisté
à la crise, mais celui dans lequel on est non.
Juste en bas,
c'est une putain de rivière !
On est dans l'endroit le plus dangereux de l’hôtel mon gars !
Oh putain, j'ai l'impression que
quelqu'un m'a touché ! - Quoi ?
Ah ah c'est pas des conneries mais attends...
Allez commencez pas vos conneries, on avance
On va se diriger à la réception parce qu'on a vu une sorte de... de fausse biche
Hyper glauque
ça nous a tous intrigué
Et voilà
C'est l'élément le plus glauque de l'hôtel c'est sûr
Ils avaient quand même prit le temps d'emballer quelques meubles,
mais ils les ont laissés sur place, je sais pas pourquoi...
(Musique glauque, petite boite à musique)
Le moment est venu de faire des squad
Parce que être à 6 dans un lieu si étroit c'est compliqué
Du coup j'vais être avec le grand JD vu qu'on est les deux seuls euh...
...Seuls. Haha
Best video ever de le faire à trois heures du matin
Du coup, distribution des talkies-walkies !
Halo heu, Rambo Tango Charlie, over -
Salut c'est Jean-Michel, ça va ?
Ouais, merci !
Globalement on a vu la réception et des salles on sait pas trop ce que c'est,
et là on va faire les chambres de l'hôtel !
La réception est au cinquième étage de l'hôtel,
et plus bas, ce sont les chambres.
Ah ah tu sais ce qui serait flippant ?
L'enfant avec la coupe... - Oh non arrête, l'enfant avec la coupe au bol asiatique ?
Exactement le clasique !
Eh, déjà quand tu te retrouves à deux tu fais moins le malin, t'as vu ?
Ouais c'est vrai !
Rendez-vous à 4h30 à la réception ça vous va ? Over.
7h30 !?
Merde mais en fait y'a une chambre là mec ? - ça c'est une chambre ouais...
C'est la première chambre que je vois !
Bah mec... C'est un peu oppressant en fait de dormir dans cet hôtel !
Ouais - P'tin y'a zéro lumière !
Genre, tu dors entre quatre murs complètement fermés !
Alors en fait toutes les fenêtres sont à la réception...
Ouah...
C'est à couper le souffle quand même...
C'est juste dingue de voir ça.
Mais rentre, vas-y ! - Tu veux qu'on y aille ?
Ah ah ! T'sais il est pas trop sûr !
J'suis pas très serein moi...
J'ai jamais fait ça..
Putain y'a des moisissures regarde
Y'a des moisissures à fond
Y'a des yukatas mec
Mais ils sont... Il sont en trop bon état !
En super bon état !
Mais c'est immense ! C'est une suite royale ?
Nan j'crois que c'est des appartements du coup
Regarde ça !
Oh mec regarde !
C'est des photos de l'hôtel, avant qu'il soit abandonné !
Putain...
T'as vu ça ?
Juste ici c'est un Onsen (bains chauds) au pied d'une fenêtre,
Où ça ? Juste en bas ? - Attends, y'a un plan...
Moi j'pense que c'est en bas à...
Ah, quoi que... Si regarde, à côté de la rivière j'pense que c'est tout en bas
Attends vas-y on cherche d'autres trucs...
(Chuchote) C'est trop cool...
ça c'est de la pub hein, ah ah
Vive la pub de 2008 !
Ici on a...
Des annonces quoi, des trucs pour le train, pour ce qu'il y a à faire dans la région...
Des trucs touristiques quoi.
D'accord.
Ah, j'espérais qu'on trouve le prix, le prix d'une chambre
Mais c'est mort
Mais ça je pense que c'est une bonne chambre parce que t'as vu, y'a une vue sur le lac et tout
Bon à partir de maintenant on va s'enfoncer dans des étages qu'on a pas du tout vu,
Et j'aimerais bien tomber sur les Onsen putain
Même s'il ya plus d'eau ou quoi que ce soit j'aimerais bien voir à quoi ça ressemble en fait
En plus c'est du carrelage donc peut-être que ça a été mieux conservé
que la moquette ou (hésitations) le papier peint quoi, tu vois ?
Plus on descend, et plus les étages sont délabrés j'ai l'impression
Ouais c'est clair
Regarde par terre... - Ah putain ! - Tout est niqué quoi...
En plus on est enfoncés c'est horrible
Parce que là si on doit sortir on doit remonter
J'ai hyper peur de tomber sur un corps en fait, en allant dans des chambres
Regardez y'a encore les chaussons à l'entrée
Parce qu'au Japon avant d'entrer dans l'appart y'a toujours une zone où tu retires tes pompes,
et ensuite tu mets des chaussons comme ça pour avancer.
Là-bas je vois un matelas mec mais c'est un peu... Un peu flippant !
Rho putain dès qu'y a de la literie t'façon c'est tellement glauque mec
T'amènes vraiment ta famille
Mec, on dirait qu'on est venu les kidnapper en pleine nuit !
Regarde, c'est normal d'avoir ça ?
Les mecs sans déconner, y'a encore la bouffe !
J'arrive pas à comprendre
comment les lieux peuvent être abandonnés comme si y'avait les gens,
Et on leur a dit : "Aller maintenant dégagez tout de suite !"
Et ils sont sortis en pyjama tu vois...
ça c'est typique au Japon y'a plein de lieux comme ça, et tu trouveras que ça au Japon
On n'est pas du tout les premiers à venir dans ce bâtiment et certainement pas les derniers,
Mais en fait les gens respectent les lieux. Ils touchent rien, ils laissent tout exactement comme c'était au moment où ils sont rentrés.
Et du coup t'as des scènes de vie... Sans vie.
C'est glauque. T'as les lits, t'as la bouffe, t'as tout qui est en état assez correct
Tout est placé comme si les gens étaient partis hier
On n'a pas l'impression que c'était y'a neuf ans les dernières personnes qui on loué des chambres
Nan c'est clair
(Tape le tiroir)
Si ça se trouve t'as fait du bruit, et les autres ils ont eu peur ?
Est-ce que tu veux faire une blague aux autres ?
Nan, nan c'est pas bien !
On entends de l'eau, écoutez !
Y'a un bruit d'eau...
Y'a un truc qui ruisselle... - Oh putain
J'crois qu'on a trouvé les bords
Ah oui ! La rivière est juste de l'autre côté en fait, d'accord !
La rivière est de l'autre côté de ce mur !
Donc là on rentre dans une sorte de petite cuisine...
Y'a une porte là.
C'est le couloir, c'est le couloir. Allez viens, on fait le tour.
Là on s'est vraiment éloignés de...
On s'est éloignés de plus en plus des autres...
Des autres groupes. On est un peu perdus...
Tout se passe bien pour vous ? Over.
Là on rentre dans une sorte de petite cuisine...
(Le son du Talkie-Walkie saute)
Eh les mecs ?
(Réponse) Ouais ça va ? Over.
Ouais tout va bien pour nous on s'enfonce petit à petit,
on cherche des Onsen. On est aux chambres 300 et quelques là. Over.
Y'a un caillou de l'autre côté de la fenêtre. Un énorme caillou.
Ah c'est pas la partie de l'hôtel qui s'est effondrée ?
Ah ah, j'en sais rien
Benoit nous a expliqué qu'y a une partie de l'hôtel qui est tombé dans la rivière à un moment.
Et du coup je pense qu'on voit ici les roches extraites de ce dernier.
(Rire nerveux) Pourquoi tu ralentis comme ça ?
J'sais pas dès qu'il y a une porte mec j'ai super peur !
C'est juste dingue ce qu'on est en train de vivre, putain.
Un lieu abandonné aussi immense !
Tout ce que j'avais vu moi, c'était au mieux une petite maison tu vois.
J'avais jamais fait de bâtiment entier comme ça
C'est juste... dingue à découvrir.
Oh, putain ! Ils m'ont fait peur !
Vous m'avez fait super peur les gars.
Oh mec !
Incroyable !
La découverte de la mascotte de la coupe du monde de ?
1900... 98 ?
C'est ça !
Wow !
Pouah !
Je sais pas c'que c'était que cet endroit mais...
Il est explosé !
Ouah...
(CRACK) Ah ah, ça va vieux ?
ça va. Mais voilà ce qui peut arriver !
Ouaouh.
Ma caméra est dégueulasse quoi. Y'a tellement de particules...
Aller vas-y on va aux Onsen c'est en-dessous
Prêt pour le dernier étage ?
Aller.
Aller on y va.
(Cri aigü) AAAAH !
PUTAIN !
Ah ah, oh putain !
Et voilà !
On s'est fait niquer !
Plus on s'enfonce plus y'a des odeurs bizarres
En fait on descend les étages et y'a vraiment des odeurs bizarres...
Ah il monte aux... Bah, monte aux Onsens
Hey c'est cool comme Onsen en vrai !
Ouais ils sont assez funs. C'est de l'autre côté !
Ouah y'a les petits casiers pour mettre ses affaires personnelles !
Wow ! Donc là...
C'est là où tu te douches
Tu te laves en fait
Avant de rejoindre le bain
Qui est... Ici !
Et donc en fait du coup ici t'as un bain à... 40 degrés
Ici, à 45
Nozman il est plutôt 45
Ouais, moh..
Et ici généralement t'as juste un bain à 20-21 degrés, une température normale quoi.
Donc ça c'est les bains pour hommes,
ou les bains publics. En fait ça dépend des horaires mais y'a des fois où c'est mixte.
Vu que c'est des hôtels et non pas des vrais Onsen.
Eh vraiment y'a un (s'interrompt pour éviter la lampe) Oh putain !
Et apparemment y'a aussi un Onsen pour les femmes !
Qui est quelque part par ici...
(Chantonne) Eeeeet les Onsens féminins !
Clairement je préfère ceux des femmes !
(Divers cris de stupéfaction)
Hey c'est beaucoup plus beau !
Avec des petites fontaines et tout !
Et là c'est... Oh putain elles on carrément un Onsen contre les vitres !
Regarde ça !
Mais attends mais c'est...
Mais c'est magnifique elles c'qu'elles ont !
Ah ah ! Non mais je pense pas que ça soit les Onsens des femmes les gars.
J'pense que ça c'est le mixte, et là-bas c'est celui des femmes.
C'est là où y'a tous les bains contres les vitres
Où tu vois la rivière couler.
Regarde ça c'est le "Okoyu"
Il reste même les indications
Le "Kisetsu Boro" (chiffons de saison)
Tu vois ça indique j'pense la température et pourquoi le bain est fait
Genre quand c'est très chaud c'est pour te relaxer les muscles, etc.
'Fin là j'dis une énorme connerie mais c'est.. c'un exemple. - Ah ah
Et bien mes amis comme JD viens de si bien le dire,
On a terminé de visiter ces lieux.
(Musique de petite boîte à musique)
Ben les amis merci pour ce moment !
C'était une belle visite. Tu nous a trouvé un très bel hôtel abandonné, Benoit. merci à toi.
Pas de problème.
C'était ouf. N'hésitez pas à aller voir la chaîne de tous ces gens ici-présents.
Que ce soit le grand JD, que ce soit Nozman, que ce soit Benoit !
Et abonnez à Luc Annez  et mettez pleins de pouces bleus sur ses vidéos, comme ça.
C'EST IMPORTANT
(Bafouille) N'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si ça vous a plu !
Comme d'hab- (Pouffe)
Faut qu'on aille dormir tout de suite !
Tchao tout le monde, PEACE ! Incroyable...
Adapté aux sourds et malentendants par YokaMycelium